and they just looked you up in a way and
then hope you will stop drinking no oh
no no no first of all they bring in your
parents and your parents have to sit in
the room and say blah blah blah you were
you know you have ruined your life you
have made a show of me you know it was
really hard for them and they brought in
my flatmate my sisters they all said you
are an alcoholic this is you know
ridiculous then they brought in people
from my work you know so it was tough
love it was about breaking through there
the shell of denial that any addict has
I mean it was hard and then it was
amazing like it was truly the best thing
that ever happened to me and even now
it's in Dublin where I live now any time
I pass it I feel such love for the
people I mean that they they completely
changed me and I suppose one of the
things I did understand from the six
weeks I spent in there was that I would
never be able to engage with alcohol in
a healthy way again like the love affair
was over but do you do you have like an
addictive personality totally I am
addicted to everything everything I mean
name me anything
chocolates shoes bracelets makeup men
although I'm I am married I am married
I'm married I just look it's okay yeah
no no no he does hear it but he's a very
very tolerant man he's loving Swedish I
tell you I love the sound of Swedish
being spoken has the most calming effect
on me I'm not joking and I watch
enormous amounts of Swedish television
Swedish television yeah yeah yeah I do
like like like drama or this show but
not this show sadly because I need
subtitles please
and I am here in Stockholm and so why
are you not white why am I not getting
the lines of English underneath all your
sentences I don't understand
help me know if you wrote it let's say
you could name is it only Swedish or or
even the other it's kinda Scandinavian
and may I say I love this woman I my
watchdog are you are Malin I'm sorry I
know you have another name here today it
to me you are Malin
when I saw you were here like did you
not feel the love that I was sending
character in us and I love you all the
different clothes you wear yeah fabulous
you are going let me look so you have a
huge fan base in Ireland yeah we'd have
a parade for you ok let's let's name ok
because could you name like like a for
Nordic series Vilander both kinds I have
Krister I have Rolf
yes are any down your tyranny down yes
Lord Scott your size back a lot of
killing I hear yes bridge the bridge yes
yelling again yes crimes of passion
killing yeah you kidding yes yeah we
don't have any comedy we need to have
your show yeah yeah we I sound like we
have a parade for you
Phoenix yes absolutely they they will
have a day for you as well yes parades
for everyone you've been called the
pioneer in the genre chicklets yes but
you don't like that term do you when I
personally don't mind it because I feel
very lucky to have the life I have and
you know I get to write books that I
love but I feel I'm really sorry to
sound like a strident feminist Bush I am
a strident feminist and it's a term
that's used to denigrate things that are
written by women about women for women
and the horrible fact remains that men
still I'm very fond of men but men have
more power and more money than most
women and one of the ways that people
kind of tend to hold on to those things
is to mock the people that might be
saying hello can I have some of your
money hello can I have some of your
power so it's a chiclet is is there is a
label that kind of goes oh it's only by
little girls for little girls you know
so I don't like the term because I think
it's just another way of making life a
bit harder for women who have things a
bit harder already are you are you also
aware of of Scandinavian rock music okay
no well you'll be found in just a minute
you know thank you so much for being
with us today and as you pleasure thank
you thank you please welcome Mary Ann
Keith